president biden hitting the road to
highlight the already passed stimulus
bill from last week but he's got no
plans for a trip to the southern border
even as his administration sends fema to
help
yesterday a group of republican
lawmakers got a firsthand look at the
border crisis including
our next guests joining us now new
mexico congresswoman yvette harrell
tennessee congressman john rose and
congressman dave joyce and
uh congressman harrell let's start with
you what did you expect what did you see
well i was impressed that the facility
is obviously brand new it's been open
just a year
um when they built this they thought
that they would never reach capacity but
while we were there yesterday we were
told by chief chavez that they
actually did indeed meet their capacity
yesterday
and are looking for overflow
opportunities even out in their parking
lot but the facility is very nice
considering the trek these people came
through to get to
our border congressman rose who was in
there who were in these facilities
well we saw a combination of families uh
unaccompanied minors and uh individual
adults
that are being processed at this
facility obviously the unaccompanied
minors
uh maybe is the is the most tragic of
the stories congressman rose
did you see a situation where uh where
it was an overwhelmed facility are we
getting to that point
i think we're getting to that point this
facility has was
built to accommodate about a hundred
thousand just over a hundred thousand
uh uh individuals or i'm sorry just over
a thousand individuals and they exceeded
that capacity yesterday so i think
uh they are planning for what they
believe will be a rising surge
we're at about 50 percent more than at
any previous point
at this point in the year congressman
joyce uh in terms of
where they're from what they hear why
they came
uh i know speak the language barrier is
an issue but did you get some of the
stories uh i did not
personally because i i'm not that fluent
in spanish but uh congressman jimenez i
know had a discussion with the family
that
uh made the journey from haiti and in
talking to the agents you find out that
they're coming from all over the world
china especially and china being the big
fish because they'll actually pay 35 000
to be brought into the country well but
one of the most staggering statistics i
heard yesterday was the idea that
they're paying on the average of four
thousand dollars uh
to have these coyotes push them into the
country now think about that last some
not just last month
they've caught a hundred thousand that's
400 million dollars
so there's a and that and think of the
people we didn't catch so there's a huge
financial incentive for this to occur as
well let's take a look at some of the
stats the southern border migrating
migration encounters we have a full
screen 100 441 came in february of 2021.
that's stunning that's up 28 from
january up 174
from february 2020 the highest since
june of 2019.
so this is stunning congressman uh
congresswoman
harrell when you look at this situation
where is this heading where are we going
to be in three weeks where we're going
to be in a month
oh it's certainly this is a crisis at
the border and it really didn't have to
be this way and in fact
one of our colleagues i think said it
best yesterday uh congressman mike
mccloud said
you know this administration could have
done nothing and it would have been
better than it is right
now because we know the policies of
president trump are working with the
remain in mexico
right now we're hoping that they keep
the title 42 in place
that is actually what's helping that's
the public health order
that allows border patrol agents to
process on the border
those that are coming here illegally
from mexico or canada and then expel
them back to
mexico or canada that is uh one of the
tools that is working the board patrol
told us yesterday that has been a
godsend they hope that that title 42
stays in place and we've actually
introduced legislation doing just that
so we're hoping that we can get some
legs under that piece of legislation and
get it through so that we can keep that
available for our board patrol agents
and for the country
unaccompanied miners you have 9457 in
february
so congressman rose when they turn
around and say this is all
trump's fault it was broken policies
broken border we inherited what's your
reaction
well i think that's ridiculous i think
that president biden's
message that he sent that the border
would be open and that
these individuals should come is
encouraging them to come and putting
those people in harm's way as they make
the perilous journey north
and so i think it's ridiculous to lay
this at the feet of
of president trump because clearly this
is biden's
crisis it's biden's scandal and he won't
even admit it and he will not let the
border patrol talk about it but yet the
stress is overwhelming
uh congress people have to leave it
there harold rose
and joyce thanks for making the journey
giving us your personal uh
account of what you saw rather than
reports and what you read
thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you you got it